[Music]
um
hey everyone welcome to the corridor
cast we are back today we've got nico
we've got sam we've got clinton we've
got myself
right only i had like two more seconds
to practice that yeah
i actually played it all the way through
just a little too late um anyways last
second ideas all right
nico did you summon did you summon this
cast yeah some of this cast because
we just recently had one of the most
important days of the year here at
corridor which is the annual smash
brothers tournament and you might be
like oh
god video games and like listen we're
going to tell you the story of
a cultural phenomenon in the office
because
you've seen it hints of it here and
there in the videos you may have seen
some instagram posts
but smash brothers has become a thing
that dominates our free time it's a
corporate
mono culture yeah and everyone usually
thinks that's a bad thing
whether it's like political leanings of
mega tech giants or blah blah blah
here at quarter digital there are three
corporate monocultures that are are
taking place
a corporate tri-culture tricultures it
it's a tri-force
of culture on one side there's an
electric vehicle aka a one wheel
on the other side there's bone
conducting headphones
and and at the top of that triangle
is smash brothers
everyone in the office fits perfectly
onto this triangle
yep with at least two of them except for
one or two but it's okay they
they give them give them some time
there's so there's subcultures like the
the pants you know the kombucha
subculture the kombucha
culture um that triangle is the one that
unites
everyone it's the most powerful triangle
yeah so just to give you guys an idea of
what we're talking about
so on my switch which was for a while
like the office switch that was [ __ ]
the tv
oh yeah so for a while it was mostly
just you know me
i have 650 hours of smash brothers
played on the switch over 5 000 games
that's like communal that's communal
it's communal you can't take obviously
you're not here you're taking credit
i'm not taking credit no no yeah
obviously nico's put in some time
himself
um you know when practicing for the
tournaments when going on
texas trips uh different productions on
the airplane he's playing smash
but usually it's nico switch in the dock
and it's got a lot of hours logged
it's also important to note we didn't
start playing with the dock on a tv
until well after a year into our playing
as a culture
which is crazy we all played for the
longest time the entire first year of us
playing
was just local wireless those office
chairs you hear
one person starts scooting their chair
across the office floor yeah and then
everyone perks up and
suddenly it's just like a cacophony of
office chairs rolling into this
congregation you'd make eye contact with
each other from across the office and be
like
a little smirk and a nod or like an
eyebrow raise and the other person would
nod quickly
did we got so many people in the office
chair smash bros circle
that we got lag issues because we were
so far apart
yeah you couldn't get enough people in
the circle yeah but all you have to do
is
you know i walk in and i just look at
dean and
and he knows i'll see you upstairs all
right yeah it's just
dean it's dean and myself have a special
relationship now too where dean
stands up and he says sam i say
yes and then we begin a match
and i told i told him early on i said
dean
if it's ever about something that's not
smash related
i'm going to say no but if it's smashed
i'm going to say yes
dude dean and i like our tables are
basically parallel to each other but
we're facing opposite directions
and i'd sit there and look over and make
eye contact we wouldn't say a thing we
wouldn't even do anything else other
than just slowly reach
while maintaining eye contact the whole
time slowly reach for a switch
and just grab it and then we go on yeah
by the way i must say
the switch is the greatest thing
to happen uh in the last i don't know to
video games
yeah basically it really is well there's
there's like such a trend right now for
video games to become a thing where it's
like there's
updates and patches and downloads and
online connectivity all needed
so really if you're a man on the go like
me
you need a thing where you turn it on
you're playing a game within
three seconds of turning it on right if
i'm going to have a dedicated video game
machine
when i hit the power button i expect it
to turn on and immediately present me
with video game
yeah video games just the fact that you
can like
i mean we go on one wheel rides and play
on the top of mountains
yeah yeah like that is kind of the best
thing ever freaking cool
that you can just bust out the switch
and play anywhere
and like you don't get lag issues unless
you know your
your smash bros circle is too big well
it also has to do with like
wi-fi congestion like here in the studio
where there's wi-fi waves
everywhere it's uh it's a little hard on
top of a mountain where there aren't
many waves you can spread out a little
bit
so when smash first came out which was
like two years ago it was december 2018.
so when it first came out like i hadn't
hadn't really played smash before like i
played it before but i hadn't like
i didn't know what made the game special
and i knew that people took the game
seriously i knew there's a lot of
following for it
i knew there was depth to it but i
didn't know what that was when i started
playing it and so i made a point of
watching some youtube videos and
getting the introduction and it started
to click you know there's a lot of like
rock paper scissors type scenarios in
the game there's the mentality of
conditioning your opponent
and changing it up to take advantage of
that conditioning and just other like
you know move systems that are
consistent through all the characters
while each character has their own
little special tweaks about them
like you can pick pretty much any
character and at least have a base set
of rules the fighting follows
so you're not learning a thousand
different systems and
it really it really grips me because
it's like so clean
you know you're playing a very fast game
of chess against somebody else
and then the beauty of the nintendo
switch where you can just you can have
it anywhere you can link with anybody
right away
you can get a room up and you can start
playing within a couple seconds
and then the games last you know a
couple minutes at most
it became this perfect thing where like
you know we have a bit of a work ethos
here it's like you work really hard you
focus
you get an hour or two and you just need
a little break you know just
like unwind for a second shift gears and
it's like a 10 minute break
and smash is like perfect for that like
three rounds of smash is like a perfect
10 minute 15 minute break
and you go right back to working for the
next hour or two and you feel refreshed
and like even now it's consistently
there's at least three sessions in a day
there's in the morning session the lunch
session in the after work session yeah
yeah
and that bread this this culture where
we started playing because we'd all be
cranking on stuff like in a lot of
the you know the quarter crew videos
whatever it looks like we're having a
fun time all the time and we're having
good times here but
a lot of the time like 80 to 90 percent
of the time here
is spent working you know editing
cranking through stuff i'd say more than
that
let's say like 90 95 yeah so that's when
the the switch comes out and you get
your brakes in
so that you can keep working and be and
be strong and effective
and that's when smash kind of grew into
something
christian did you have a switch when we
all started playing smash
dude you had a while it took a while for
you to switch but i remember
like the day you got to switch i was so
excited yes christian finally got a
switching placement that's right i
remember that yeah
yeah yeah i didn't have one for the
first tourney and you guys were like oh
you've
got a decent link and i was like i need
to get my own way yeah because you were
good like you
you were good without your switch but
christian are you micked up
well yeah okay good because
you got to have input on this
conversation there was even a moment
there do you remember like at the top of
this year
like where there's like too many people
playing smash brothers
right where we started getting these
like nine player games
or it's like where it's like sorry bro
this is eight
only one person has to sit out for the
games and they're just like
and it's like it's like you kind of feel
bad but not really because you're you're
gonna play smash yeah yeah where you
have it where it's like you have seven
people playing
no you have eight people who want to
play but someone's using two joy cons
which counts as two different
controllers yeah it's like dude too many
slots you need to get a broken
maximum of eight controllers that work
with smash so a joy the joy cons are the
two controllers
that you know attach to the side of the
switch but they count as individual ones
so they take up someone else's spot
yep and the thing is like the the
nintendo pro controllers are like
ridiculously overpriced they're like 70
to 80 they are expensive
yeah so most of us are playing with our
joy cons or whatever
and i think sam you were the first one
to be like screw this and you went you
bought a pro controller
i did almost the tilts man i was like
trying to i was like
like there's secret move sets in the
game that like are not apparent when you
start playing it like the concept yeah
there's like a whole tilt attack thing
which is like four new attacks for each
character
and like they're basically impossible to
do
when you're like i'm just thinking i'm
not aware of them yeah i'm just thinking
of mario kart and was like i'm using
tilt controls
yeah i know i'm like what tilt like well
dude it's all about i mean
i sat there for hours in like training
levels like trying to do these like tilt
attacks or whatever i'm like
i think i need like a longer joystick to
do this so i got a pro controller
still couldn't do it yeah no it's a very
subtle like fine
uh kind of motion that you really got to
get used to i mean that's why i love the
the game the gamecube controller you
know i brought my gamecube controller
just for this podcast if you guys are
wondering so the game we play
is smash brothers ultimate correct yes
and it is not the first smash brothers
game i think it's the fifth
yeah so the very first one was smash
bros in 66 44.
and that was the only other smash bros
game i ever played it was because my
neighbor
when i was a kid had an n64 i never had
one and he had like mario 64
pokemon snap and smash bros yep and
banjo-kazooie
yeah and uh so like the only times i
ever played
were over at his house and then like i
never played any other game so when i
got the game when all you guys got it in
december of 2018
i sucked at it i had no idea how to play
and i hate it because
i was pissed because the month before
you guys have gotten
super into dark souls yeah yeah yeah i
will never forget that trip that
minnesota trip where we're all like
constantly like trying to like
compete kind of in a weird way i felt it
felt competitive like in dark souls
yeah i was like i got this sword oh i
got this armor like i got this far like
you talking like that yeah yeah yeah i'm
just sitting there like ah
well maybe i started teaming up i was
like slightly behind you guys too
and you guys were like playing a lot and
i was frequently
not high enough level to like get in
your dark souls games
[Applause]
i just started playing by myself and you
guys are like yeah
no me and nico had a blast on that trip
you guys convinced me to buy that game i
know i spent a total of 35 minutes in
that game
i spent 60 i spent two dollars for every
minute i played that game hilarious
okay but you're funding all the future
ones that we will also enjoy
we also when i bought smash bros and was
immediately sucking at it i was like oh
man this is
ah this is dark souls all over again no
it sucked i hated it
i was not good at the game but then then
eight months goes by
every day playing with you guys and i
eventually got better at it you got
pretty good you got
you got you got all right at it and we
had the node tournament that was the
first one yeah and so that was like
two or three months by d
who doesn't even have a switch or plays
the game but d plays a lot of video
games and he's really good
yeah are generally actually good at
video games sure but i mean i thought i
was too
yeah but you keep playing that you then
you settled on bowser kind of after that
as your main character
not not wii fit trainer like i did in
that first tournament for those of you
who don't play smash brothers or really
fighting games in general
there's a concept of a main it's like
you know how ash
the the pokemon trainer has pikachu well
pikachu is basically ash's main
yeah it's the main charac cause there's
so many characters you could choose from
how many is it like six seventy
something seventy
two jesus and every character plays
slightly different they all have roughly
the same controls but it's like every
character has their own little quirks
yeah so that's what keeps the variety uh
in the game and so everyone kind of
attaches on to one character and learns
how
all the intricacies of that one
character because you get people for
timing it's like this move is going to
take this long this move is going to
take this long i can
this move is going to go this far you
start to like one character you pick
to really truly learn dude i mean the
way i think of it
is like um it's like a manual car when i
first started to learn how to drive a
manual car i was like
this is very uncomfortable makes no
sense
i don't get it i don't want to drive a
manual car anymore and then eventually
like after like two weeks i was like
okay i kind of get this
and i'm still getting better at driving
a manual car after
like eight years and
those are my favorite video games ones
that like rocket league
or even mario kart games where the high
skill ceiling
yeah it's like a never ending skill
ceiling it goes to the max
yeah you know and like i love a good
challenge and for me those are the
lifelong games
yeah and so then siren eventually
settled on bowser as his main which is a
good pick because bowser is
a heavy character with big hits who's
also fast
uh and so he trained on that and then we
had our second smash tournament in 2019
and ren also got three stalked because i
i at the last moment
i changed the character i decided to
play with in that tournament i went to
tune link
well to be fair like we we hadn't quite
hit the point where we were
technical smash players yet like some of
us were getting there i think like
like i was starting to watch some more
in-depth tutorials about a month or two
before that like remember i switched
over to trigger jump
i do remember because i was trying to
learn about like aerial attacks and tilt
attacks and all kind of stuff
and you hadn't quite invested yours you
hadn't invested yourself to that degree
yeah
because you kind of thought it's still
maybe a little silly and then i wouldn't
say that i just
i i was i was playing this game a lot
but only ever here at the studio i never
played the game at home
yeah you're still somehow casual about
it yeah for how much we played it
then after that tournament happened i
remember like leaving for christmas and
then coming back
and you were doing things with bowser
that i like had never seen before
and i was like all right ren's in and in
a way like like because we had all kind
of invested that just made me
re-doubly invest myself into the game
and everybody like we fed off each
other's energy where it's like we all
really took the time to learn how to be
the best we could at the game
to the point where like remember i think
it was easy the gear or wes
friend came in that one time and he had
like he had a controller with them
or something like that are you talking
about uh
the marvel guy maybe yeah like you
talked about turmeric
maybe yes and like aaron tony no not
aaron tony it's somebody else
if somebody else i remember i remember
yeah i remember he's like
he's like one place like i play some
smash bust it up and like he like goes
to the controls he sets up his custom
controls and stuff like that
and we're all thinking like oh finally
some like
somebody from the outside who takes the
game seriously yeah let's see how we
stack up
and like we're kind of thinking like we
might get our butt kicked by this guy he
might be pretty good we just
laid him out there's nothing it's like
it's the same with everybody like people
you know there's like stunt men react
they come in right and it's been three
times it's been with gee
aaron tony and with um who's the guy who
works with young
oh uh uh chris chris wiped
yeah wiped well i mean seriously but
like we also have this very unique
situation where if
one of us gets into something and that
kind of like spreads here
like whatever it is there's this kind of
like feedback loop that happens where
everyone
starts to excel at it in a really rapid
pace because you have
multiple people figuring it out in their
own way and sharing that information and
pushing each other and so on and so
forth so
like yeah i mean i think it just goes to
show you though that it's like it's part
of it's part of the environment though
it's like
those guys aren't in a group of like
four or five other smash players who
want to play every single day
and are very competitive about the vest
like yeah that's the other thing that's
like that happens like some i don't know
what it is about smash
that has made us do this but we have
invested ourselves so
personally in the outcome of these
battles like every day it doesn't matter
it still feels like
i mean we whisper to each other this is
the championship
this is the finals this is the finals
yeah this is the one this is the one
game
and we immediately like mentally
transport ourselves to that moment
where the whole world is watching and
the fight that you're about to that
you're about to engage in
that could be the fight the outcome of
this fight would be the fight that
you're about to do
it's weird though like it still feels
casual to me it still
feels like i mean it always feels casual
to me yeah like even the tournament to a
certain degree felt
casual oh no i was shaken during the
tournament you stopped talking
that's the biggest indication that he
wasn't focused
yeah me neither you were playing you
were like an overclocked processor at
the tournament
yeah no like that for me like i'm very
competitive
oh god i have so many freaking stories
of just failing during competitions
oh i know it always had dude it always
happened
what's like a really good competition
fail well the freaking mario kart one
yeah
we could have won like what was it
twenty thousand twenty thousand dollars
tell us the story again
again tell us the story god all right
i'll give you the sparknets okay so
basically
disney xd and was holding this like
influencer mario kart tournament and
jimmy was like dude i can't go i need
you to
i need you to cart in my stead and i was
like dude
i will not let you down because me and
jimmy we go back
we go way back when it comes to mario
kart and um i was just telling red like
we had some of the best memories
ever playing a video game with jimmy
playing mario kart so i'm like dude i
got you
is that the youtube space big production
they probably spent like 50k
on it maybe more who know dude the prize
pool was 20 thousand dollars
if you won the mario kart and you're
like on day and like
all these other random youtubers like
dude they don't even play mario kart
they don't know
that i play mario kart every day with
jimmy like
me and jimmy are like drifting side by
side like throwing bananas in front of
us and like
spinning them out right before the
finish line taking first place
like they don't even stand a chance so i
go in there and i
you know get through the through all the
the bs you know
races get to the semi-finals
preliminaries whatever
so we're in the green room no this is
the this is the semi-finals
and i find out there is an input lag
it's like it's bad it's a two second
input lag
two single input like unplayable yeah
meaning if i turn right you're going to
turn right in two seconds
so you have to have the foresight like
that's you're you're it's like doing a
race
in real life with all these intricate
turns
and you have to make the decisions two
seconds before it's impossible on a game
that is measured on milliseconds
seriously and i somehow get through
the semi-finals and we're we're we're in
the green room
there's a live audience wait so but
you're playing with this leg
and you're going like something's up no
i'm going with this i'm playing the
slack i'm saying this is garbage
everybody fix this now like
there's a twenty thousand dollars on the
line i'm gonna win this
i know i'm gonna win this yeah i'm not
gonna have this lag screw me over
for twenty thousand dollars like what
the heck
so to get through all of the races i
guess you're in the green room
exactly i'm in the green room and i'm
just like everyone let's train
right now and it was um i trained like a
week before 200 cc
on a on a wiimote you're playing on
wiimotes
sideways sideways
which is like the jankiest way to play
but i'm like no i'm going to win this um
so i'm just crushing everybody in the
green room they're giving me handshakes
saying you got this congrats
and they fixed the input lag i'm like ah
this is great
and then you know comes time for the big
moment
the live crowd is there they got food
and snacks everywhere
it's late it's like 7pm um it's a party
late i mean it's it's like it's a night
right so i go up on stage and
and they're like the input lag is back
we're sorry and i'm like oh no
and i didn't get first place what you
can't just skip to the end like that
i mean i could hype it up i mean it was
moomoo meadows and
i was dodging mud slicks left and right
and
yeah i lost because who did you lose to
some freaking guy dude who like a
youtuber an influencer i don't even know
i don't even how many people are racing
four
eight uh i think it was four yeah on
stage was four people okay
i'm sick of my stomach just talking
about this like twenty thousand dollars
down so i
yeah so someone won twenty thousand
dollars
because two seconds were enough to cause
you to hit a
mud skip so i i always biff mudkip
in these competitions like last
competitions sam
tell the story of last competition so
the the second
smash tournament is what i think you're
referring to right yep
all right you someone else thought story
so so we have our first annual smash
tournament
which we have uh over in unit six in the
old node headquarters
it's cool you know it's like we're kind
of figuring out the vibe none of us are
particularly
special at the game yet i take home the
belt i feel great
it's a life accomplishment you'll never
take that from me
anyways second tournament rolls around
next year next year one year later
we're all taking it at least i'm taking
it completely seriously so all of us
are taking i was even taking it
seriously i was very serious about it
so it's real competition here there's no
prize except from just being the best
because i think it's like
it's not about winning a trophy or a
prize at the tournament it's about the
next day when you come into the office
and you say i'm the best and then no one
can argue with you well it's also
like saying that like this is how i feel
like i need to represent my
myself in a way that i feel is accurate
and
when you go into a competition you want
to win because you feel like
you've put in all the work to train for
this fight yeah
definitely so so the tournament's going
and there's some great games going on
like the clint versus
cliff matchup is beautiful like it has
a stunning ending a twist ending if you
will
it's just a good time all around we are
playing you know we may not be pros at
the game compared to the true top pros
but amongst our group we are all playing
at our best versus each other and it is
thrilling and exciting so we get to the
matchup
that i think is like the semifinals it's
clint versus sam
well i mean real quick sam got to the
semifinals because he beat me
handedly i got three stalked again
because at the last moment i decided to
play his tone link instead of bowser
because i think
i was playing like a day or two before
and i was doing all right with tune link
and so i think clint it was you you're
like hey you should play tune link in
the tournament i was like
i think you're right i'm gonna throw out
all the training i did the last several
months i'm gonna use two links i mean
sam was just like he's like freaking
puppeting me in
into three stock territory so yeah this
is semifinals
it's san francisco in one bracket and i
believe it's me versus dean in the other
bracket
i think so and the winner then goes on
to the finals
i beat dean which is great
so for the record i felt confident
against my match with you
if i can get through you had a good ness
you had a good nest then yeah and my
ganondorf was not ready to fight your
nest
i was every once in a while i was ready
for the final fight it would have been
like a 60 40 yeah this is all irrelevant
though anyways
anyways so clint's fighting sam they
start the game
and sam playing zelda he uses the upbeat
attack all the time which teleports you
and sam accidentally right off the bat
teleports himself off the stage
i die and i just i was like dude this is
it's over for me i
i screwed that up sam's heart sinks so
far
says a man who wears his heart in his
sleeve and you could
you could feel emanating for him just
the sorrow the waves of sorrows like
this tournament's over for me yeah it's
like i was like i was like i'm gonna
keep fighting but
against clint there's no way i can do
this with
one life down so clint loves honor and
he's very nice
and and a good episode and a good
episode so clint
throws himself off the edge of the stage
too and gives sam a homie stock
in other words clint makes it evens the
tables yeah he makes it
instead of three versus three lives it's
two versus two lives no you say you say
you know and he's it's a homie stock you
say it's honor but
no honestly could it have been
arrogance i think i would be lying if i
said no
were you like i'm so good that i'm gonna
even the tables
and still be no i was thinking how
incredible would it be
if i could and i like it was all of
those things it was i
i definitely felt bad at first i was
like that sucks do you want people to
know
that you beat sam ferriss because you're
the better player
not because sam accidentally killed him
exactly yeah so it was all of those
things together
yeah so what ended up happening well we
had a great old fight
and it was a good game and it was pretty
tight and uh
at the end i eventually uh beat clint
dude i was so excited i whacked you off
the stage and it
felt like i was like wow well maybe
nobody cheered no one's quiet no one
cheered it was yeah
silence i mean kind of do you want to
talk about what happened next yeah that
never made it to the video
yeah yeah you guys had a rematch we
didn't have that
i remember it so that was what happened
the match ended and and clint was like
oh
you're hating on yourself and no one was
like no
yeah you guys decide you know what
please play again you fell to your death
you gave him a homie stock it was like
it's not a good situation let's try
again and clint ended up winning
and then like solidly and that was when
i remember no one
said anything no one shared everyone
just kind of like looking around what
did we do
and it was like everyone kind of
realized no one feels good about this
right now
it was awesome so we just decided to
pretend that second match never happened
it was awkward i felt pretty awkward
about that for like the next
week or two i just remember coming in
like i couldn't look at clint
i was like i feel kind of bad about what
happened to him i felt bad too
like i went home and i was just i was
just
kim kim was like so this this last um
competition we had sure okay real quick
this podcast will probably come out
before the tournament results come in
do we want to spoil it don't spoil it
screw it yeah okay
sure if you don't want to hear about how
this tournament went you want to see it
fresh pause here and come back to it
so before you know i i i tell
um my fiance i say hey i'm going
into a smash bros match again
third year and she was like
um you were really upset last time
when you came home and you were kind of
like jacked up for like a few days
so just it's just a game
um a good reminder yeah it's like so the
last video game tournament you competed
in was
yeah really messed you up sent you into
the uh
do a depression no literally it was bad
if you're gonna go play video games
again
just watch out for those common
challenges you might face
yeah so when we when so sam wins the
semifinals i win the semifinals now it's
me and sam in the finals
me the previous champion sam the new
up-and-comer
who theoretically dishonorably got into
the finals
i won't say those words i got it i got
into the finals
on a technicality yeah that's a good way
of putting you got all the tacticality
no i i think is the arrogance anyways
the whispered
the whispered rumors surrounding this is
that if sam doesn't win this
then it was all for naught sam needs to
take the song if sam takes us home he
proves that
the victory over clint was legitimate
and just because
seriously yeah that's the only way
because so i yeah i did beat you and i
got a championship it was great
so that that was why i needed this but
that's the thing because it's like if
you would have beat me that's why
you would yeah if you would have beat me
it would have proven that i was the
lesser player
and that that whole all the drama behind
that was
for nothing yeah and we could have had a
real fight and said between you and
clint
instead we actually got a real fight
yeah yeah no that was the best way it
could have gone
um i'm glad that me jumping off the
stage didn't in turn like
ruin yeah the ending experience i beat
you and then clint
blue ghost was there watching you know
smiling
yep i was i was that was the best thing
that could have happened
was sam win that second year um
does it make you feel better i needed
something i needed something
so let's take it to year three so again
let's take it to this year
this year oh my god you're three
tournament number three
there are more people playing in this
year's tournament than last year right
we got
16 people we even we even got the bottom
feeders you know like the the
little the little smash bro
uh i don't know the people who don't
play
i mean clint's first match was against
daniel who doesn't play
any video game i know he got like a and
claire was pissed because
man i didn't even get a warm-up yeah
that was
daniel was i don't know he didn't he
refused to play yeah though i wasn't
very confused
because he was like who won what
happened what happened i think he's
allergic to competition
we can we can speculate all kinds of
things but he just didn't want to be
there
so he he basically jumped off the map
three times in a row right away
he had a lot of work to do and he's like
why are you bothering me with this video
game see daniel is the one growing up in
the office
to all of us so guys i'm trying to be
responsible and finish my work well
jake was here you know jake left
basically oh yeah
yeah not left jake moved to texas he's
still yeah
you guys yeah he left but yeah yeah left
to texas
yeah like jake needs to know that
someone here at least make him proud he
went to the gas station to buy
cigarettes
never came back he one wheeled to the
gas station
he never came back anyways so daniel's
just like whatever i'll just go through
the motions and he jumps off the stage
and it's down and
which i was just getting i was like dude
come back here let me beat you up
at least my fight against carmichael was
like a bit of a
challenge yeah yeah yeah i think fight
against carmichael yeah
peter was a little bit of a challenge
too peter and carmichael both came in
and there's like whoa
don't worry about jordan george there
was these moments where
they could have won jordan air dodged to
grab the ledge
i was like that's that's pro
i don't know if she knew she did it but
like there was a moment there where you
carmichael could have beaten you
no he didn't get close to beating me
like that the first stock was
that first doctor he was messing with me
i was unprepared for that first stop was
it
wasn't on a temple or no no um a high
roll castle
yeah this is a nervous conversation
because it's like i went in thinking all
right carmichael doesn't stand a chance
against me he's never played this game
turns out behind the scenes even though
he doesn't own a switch or has ever
played smash bros he started watching
tons
or he said 36 hours of tutorials and he
read the manual twice
that's what he said to me i don't
believe him
but i do believe some of it i do believe
he actually put effort into learning how
to play the game
i think well it showed it did that's the
thing like i was expecting to just grab
him and then just keep punching him over
and over again
just because he wouldn't know how to get
out of it and so i kept trying to do it
meanwhile he's just like
dealing damage to me i'm like what is
happening see it's those
those unknowns i find to be so exciting
also the inspiration that like even
people who don't play the game
get competitive about the game yeah and
so like what's gonna happen
will i actually have a challenge will
someone finally be able to make me feel
alive
you know yeah anyways
so clint moves on in the first game
without too much trouble
i mean zero trouble who'd you play
against second
dean oh that was the second game yeah oh
wow so basically
i'm sorry i'm sorry sorry i played
against sam yeah second match
which was fun i was i was nervous very
nervous yeah yeah well like
we for this one we made it so you didn't
have to play the same character
throughout the tournament you could
switch it during matches
and i really wanted to mess with
everyone's heads by like going like i'm
playing samus i'm playing samus like
it's a new character it's like a
different match-up and then
basically i i i was telling everyone
else i'm gonna play
zelda against clint but make you think
that i was gonna play samus
so just you could have that like
shocking reveal of like oh i got this in
the bag i got this and i selected zelda
and you're like oh
dude it was a shock i thought for
everyone i didn't know you're gonna do
it everyone's like oh
yeah you beat clinton with the year
before yeah beat quote unquote as we all
know and we have to put quotes around
that
well i i didn't tell you this yet sam
but um
i had no i didn't know but i had
a session with my good buddy adam um who
is
who's better than me at the game he's
freaking amazing
and he mains zelda and
i played his zelda and just lost
constantly over the weekend
oh so you were getting some last minute
training specifically on zelda
not knowing i said he's probably gonna
play samus
show me your samus and i like i too
stalked with samus and i was like and he
he said you don't have an issue with
samus it's fine
and i was like just give me your best
give me your best and play zelda and i
couldn't beat them
so i i got that training for zelda
wow yeah it kind of worked out in the
end yeah so clint beats sam
yep and that takes us to the semi-finals
finals
yeah so i was real nervous about the
match with sam um
more nervous than the match with dean
because i'd played more against
dean and done well we should pause here
we should talk about dean for a second
yeah we haven't
actually talked about it i'm gonna go
get him i'll go get him you guys okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna introduce dean here
like a real son of a [ __ ]
he's a real yeah like there's good
people and then there's dean
dean was kind of the first new hire
of our new higher speed over the last
year he was the first editor we hired
ruins people's lives
and he came in great at editing great
filmmaking got a good eye on all this
stuff but he was also
fantastic at smash brothers just like
randomly i was like
pure happenstance he came in smash here
and he's like oh yeah i play smash two
and we're like who do you play and he's
like
i play king ddd which was
i'm like excuse me i'm about to fire you
dean
why is that sam because i played king
ddd
that was my name and didn't you guys
actually have
like a semi-official match no we did we
uh for the one of the live streams that
uh
that month we the live stream was
the the grudge match between dean and me
and what was at stake though there was a
couple things there's two things it was
we were both going to play king ddd
oh i remember this by the way is this
the winner is this the
amateurs podcast
i told you guys is this like oh i just
started playing smash it's such a fun
game
oh you know i was prepared to start
singing praises to you
and you have just changed my mind no we
we really gave you a good intro
that would warm your heart especially
from sam just don't listen to the
podcast afterwards the smack talk
the smack talk is part of it though the
smack talk is part of the game there's
so much smack talk
between me and you when we go at it and
it's just like we know
that when it really comes down to it
it's all about respect it's all like
it's like samurai like in a duel like
you bow to each other exactly but then
it's like yo you sure you're such trash
each other and you like slip a middle
finger in there
no dean is honestly such trash like he's
like
dude i have i have an actual sorry to
interrupt your story but i have like a
real problem with oh yeah the end of the
story is that dean won the ddd match and
i was reading
i was quite angry is that you would have
to stop playing king dedede and buy
an amiibo for the other players yeah to
this day i have it on my desk yep i know
it reminds you of all your best
uh moments which are few and far between
i mean i still knock that amiibo down
from time to time and just lay it on its
side just to let dean know that like
you still got a ways to go brother dude
i was going to say though i have like a
serious problem with with with video
games and like any kind of competition
where
i mean i'm like generally kind of a nice
guy like i think
but like when i start playing video
games i'm like such a piece of [ __ ]
to people in any competition i like talk
so much smack i don't know yeah you can
get kind of mean
sometimes yeah it's part of the fun i
feel like it's the fun though because
it's fun to get me back you know you're
like yeah it doesn't matter yeah yeah
because we're talking about
tiny cute little nintendo characters
like yeah children's
you know there's like a little guy with
a fishing pole and you're like [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
so dean we were telling the story about
how clinton has choked
wait i always get the mic dude eli talks
about how much i
choke all the time dude so we're telling
we're telling the story about how clint
chokes in high pressure situations
and uh we got through you know his mario
kart loss we got through
his uh second tournament loss but we
didn't well we didn't get to was the
first tournament lost but that's just
because you're using crappy controllers
but now we're on to the third tournament
he's beating sam he's coming around the
bend
and it's semifinals and it's he's got to
fight you
oh yeah he he choked hard man well okay
tell the story of the i want to say he
choked
right away i'm okay with what happened
well i just
i think everyone can kind of figure out
by now dean won this matchup
but clint was kicking your butt at first
he was i mean i was most worried about
clinton the tournament because like
he was we were playing a couple days
before and you were whooping me i was
locked in hard
you were like i was like oh my god did
he train with like the professional
smash player again like
is he in the matrix right now but um
yeah
i mean you were actually first two
stocks
i think i had you pretty well i i felt
like very
um cautious and timid on those like
right
right the first stock and leading up to
most of the second stock i felt like i
was being too cautious and i
i think you had the upper hand until the
end of the second stock
yeah end of the second stock i felt like
i felt something change
and i was like oh no something's
changing like clint he's just pulling
out those forward airs and she's like
that's that's the thing when you get in
that rhythm with ness of like
oh that was those aerials come out so
fast got juggled
that was the end of the second stop was
you you spent like a full minute without
being able to touch the ground
just lightning bolt after lightning bolt
just like no matter where you are that
little lightning ball would come around
and find you and shoot you back into the
sky
yeah that was the moment where probably
everybody was like oh [ __ ] is
gonna pull us out and then uh
i kill you yeah yeah and that's 1v1 i
think i was at like 200 damage
because like i couldn't my damage was so
high that i couldn't air dodge in time
to avoid it so you just kept going
like hitting me up to the top and just
hit me off the top
and then it was that last stock and then
uh and you were doing really well in
that last stock you had a lead
it felt like a 20 seconds 30 seconds in
i was like
like just train rolling through just
like doing my combos
yeah and i'm sorry to walk you back
through it but then you just
and so then this is where i'm not
exactly sure what happened
you grabbed onto the ledge and then you
yelled and died
no i think i had played i had hit him
off or something and he was trying to
avoid
my edge guard by like going under the
ledge
but then realized oh i gotta recover so
he
you circle around the lightning hits
himself in the butt and then he
bounces off the bottom of the stage it
wasn't even that no oh you missed it
yeah so yeah exactly so what happened
was
i went off the ledge dean was trying to
throw gordos at me
i was i i positioned myself so i was
underneath
because then ness has a good jump but i
thought
my jump was gone so instead of
testing it and hitting jump and not
getting a reaction
yeah which would have saved me i think i
had my jump i could have just made it
um i upbeat too soon so
my my pk thunder went just basically
into the stage
and i couldn't circle it around and
boost myself back up and danger would
never lost him yeah because you yelled
no
very loud as you're like still close to
the stage and falling i was very
confused what had happened i was like
wait what
jump i think because it's all like all
those matches are just like a blur for
me but like
what i remember the moment of seeing
that ball of energy just disappear out
of the corner of my eye
and i was like i just wonder
like just that slow descent of the
little boy just like
his fingers slip off the ledge the
little beaten child
i wonder if um because my body was like
flashing white
you know like no it looked like you hit
yourself with it yeah it's like when you
look like your ddd yeah it looked like
you were you hit it yourself and you did
successfully do it you're just going
into the stage
it looked like you were like you you
would hit yourself with it and propelled
yourself
up no he did that like no
i'm wondering now if i could have
actually recovered from that and jumped
because i had my jump still i mean
that's the thing there's so many
would'ves
and shoulda's with all this stuff you
know it's like i don't know i feel like
that every time we play like
you'll you'll beat me and i'll be like
oh i could have just like done this
and sometimes it's just like now dark
lord dean
it reigns supreme i'm just glad it
wasn't nico again to be honest
okay so that was the thing nico and i
faced off in the semifinals as well
it was us four who were in the semi the
two the two matches in the semifinals
and this is the first time i've ever
gotten past the first round
without getting three stalked uh and i
gave nico a run for his money but he
still destroyed me and went on so
you two in the finals run for his money
i got him down to one stop that's a run
for money yeah yeah one stock yeah
it was like it was friendly competition
there's been times there's been times
when i'm fighting ren and ren handles me
because i've handled everyone here at
some point yeah it is
it is a game uh it is a dance sometimes
and if you dictate the momentum
and the other person gets hypnotized
into it you can turn it around
it happens to all of us well ren's one
of the stars of this of this tournament
simply because of the amount of
times he's able to like suicide drop
people yeah
that's right yeah what an ending that's
a great thing about smash is like this
place
it's like every single time i watch you
fight anyone i'm like randy you gotta do
it you gotta suicide drop because the
bowser character i did both nat and
carmichael yeah you can
grab a player and like basically drop
them
and commit suicide and kill both players
which requires a stock advantage
that means you have to have yeah you
have to be a head in the game and so
every time i see you playing someone
like come on do it finish them like this
finish them
and you manage in the tournament to pull
it off twice basically well the second
time was different it was
the second time was a death drop where
so as bowser wren
leaps into the air and then does like a
pile driver move or like we're just
yeah butt stop but he does it over
nothingness so if ren doesn't hit
the other player wren kills himself so
baller move and wren does it and just
annihilates the other player in like
for their last stock it's just not a
waste yeah what a way to finish again
that's something i almost
never do in any of our casual games i
just happen to do it it's a move of
dominance
it's the so
good so dean you take the game probably
is as serious if not more serious than
everybody else in the office
why is that why do you take it so
seriously uh
i actually i mean i i don't know do i
take it more seriously than everybody
else i felt like going in
to the tournament every game i was like
i kind of walked in i was just like man
it's just another game
and that helped a lot like just kind of
with nerves and like you know there's
lights on you and stuff and people are
like
right behind you child peter dean
um but i don't know i just love
i love that game man it's
that name was like of beating clint no
previous year
it was beating nick because remember
nick was terrible and i was like i said
oh that's like beating a child and sam
just goes trial beater dean
videos people comment like child beater
ds
jesus what a title dude
it's probably as bad as cuntum a jones
but i took i took ownership of it at the
end yeah and i think um
you were nervous uh i would no i was
i gotta be honest i was less nervous
than facing clint but you did
it was weird because like clint i was
way more nervous but i did way better
than i thought
with you i was like a lot more confident
but did way worse
and like people see in the video like
you were like pretty close to beating me
it was one hit it was literally at the
end i
did it it was both you guys in the
finals and you're both on your last
stock with triple digit
triple digit damage yeah yeah it could
have been anyone's game
at any moment yeah it was at a point
where like all it took was just one
lucky hit and you'd win
yeah and it was just it was like a
really i think it was just a ford air
like i killed you with ford air and it's
like that that's
something i regret like you guys talk
about hype moments like i wish i had
done some more like hype stuff
and i was because i was playing like
very carefully just like holding on just
kind of like
playing playing the space but like um
like clint in the last one when you
batted the
boomerang back at cliff yeah and
just because in the video when like
cliff threw the sound effects on like
when he gets back on the map with the
whip and he's like yeah he was so hyped
um but yeah you were saying i take the
game really seriously i don't know how
much you guys have talked about with the
game
means you but like for me it's just it's
like another thing
to get into you know what i mean and
that's what i love is like
um i was telling you recently that it
felt a lot like uh i did jiu jitsu for a
little bit and it feels very similar
where it's like
that learning curve of it's it's fun at
first
it's never like you know there's never a
point where it's like boring or like
because a lot of games
there's like a big dip in the learning
curve but smash is like always fun
and it just gets more like engaging as
you get better at it
i mean like as you get deeper into
learning combos and stuff well that's
the thing like for me
for the longest time i always just kind
of played instinctually and just like
i'm just hitting what i think feels
right in the moment and it's only been
the last like half year or so that i've
really started
basically whenever uh the last
tournament ended i got super into smash
that was when i was like
i just got destroyed and that does not
represent how good i thought i was at
this game considering how much time i
put into it so that was when i started
watching youtube videos starting to
really learn the mechanics of the game
and that was what nico was talking about
i came back and i was suddenly a lot
better
and it's like even still though it's
like i i have to like slow myself
down to not be so reactionary of just
like do this real quick and like
actually okay
in this situation i can do these two
different moves that could
you know work yeah yeah and it's a great
thing to like
you know breaks up our day you know like
you get you're deep in your work and
then it's nice to just
completely switch gears and have
something that
you're like totally you know like the
flow state like you're totally like
locked into the game
yeah and um yeah go ahead oh okay so
like as uh
to answer nico's question like how
seriously do you take this i think the
best way to measure that is like how
much time do you put into smash
outside of the studio i don't put that
much time into the game
outside of the studio like before the
turn was the first time i had booted it
up outside
of work since like a couple months ago
every now and then i go through phases
where i'll put a lot of time over the
course of a week just like a couple
evenings i'll play online or whatever
or watch youtube videos and then i'll do
none of that over the next two or three
months
yeah like i mean i'll play with you guys
when we're outside the studio
for on like a traveling production sure
yeah
but honestly for me it's like when a
tournament's coming up
honestly i just trained that one night
tournament two i trained for three
nights in a row with like
uh an ex-pro coach yeah so i took it
super seriously
before then he taught me spacing
i learned a couple things so i learned
spacing which is basically
like know your spacing
don't throw moves that aren't going to
hit and also always be right
outside of where somebody's attack is
going to land so that the second
that their their attack is done you just
move in
yes yeah so that was spacing that
actually helped my game a whole lot so
i'd like
dash back and forth back and forth
trying to bait you to do a move and i
would just run back a little bit like
when you do your forward b
or whatever with ganon like you come
right up to me and i just bat you
like that was the spacing the second
thing i learned was
uh reset um it was like reset neutral or
something like that basically if you're
getting tossed
get your goal is to get back down on the
ground and just take a breath
and restart um that was the second
biggest thing i learned
and the third thing was you can always
run you can be defensive you don't have
to fly in an attack and then i guess on
top of that
is don't keep doing things that are
getting you in trouble
also take advantage of the things that
your opponent is doing
over and over like with with dean when
he's trying to get back on the stage
you'll roll up to on onto the stage and
i know that you you usually roll up on
the stage so i'll know to as nest to run
backwards and bat you as soon as you
roll into me
and then that's where the game comes is
like i realize that you're starting to
learn that
yeah so then i'm like okay i'll jump off
the ledge and then it becomes again it's
really
like once you're that locked in it
becomes a game of guessing
what the other person's predicting what
the other person is going to do yeah and
predicting
that prediction yeah and then it just
becomes like yeah it's like chess
i've got an example of that with you
clint so it's like bowser has this flame
breath this hot cheeto breath
and nest has this ability to like throw
out this force field around you that
absorbs energy
yeah and so any time yeah and it'll heal
you so anytime i'm flame throwing you
i got to this point where like i'd shoot
a flamethrower and you
and then you throw out your energy beam
to like absorb the fire and
i got it it got to a point where i could
rely on that so i'd throw out a little
bit of fire you throw that up but i was
already canceling the fire to run up and
grab you that's good
and uh that worked for a little while
until you you learned how to beat that
which was as i'm approaching uh i do
this thing where i start splitting my
fire before i even land
you'd already have your energy uh shield
out to absorb that fire as i'm already
firing like ah so i'd cancel it but
you'd already canceled your your
shield thing at the same time and it
kept going back and forth like trying to
one-up each other's techniques
that's why i love the game so much is
because it's it's always evolving and
it's always getting
more difficult well this is why like you
know
melee is still huge in competitive
circles because even though it's a game
from
what like 2000 one game one 2001 i'm
gonna have to list
to this day people there they play on
those crt tvs
yeah like there's this guy um so like
the top players are like
fox i think like chic
um captain falcon um
and a couple others but there was this
guy
called amsa in the professional circuit
who picked up yoshi who was like a
bottom tier character
but he figured out this one like kind of
move you could do because in that game
there's a lot more
exploits called like wave dashing and
all these different things that
um they kind of have removed from the
later games
but he started running through the and
nobody could figure it out they were
like
it was like he it's like somebody had cr
created this invention
of like a new move and stuff
like that still happens i mean i don't
follow that well i have a friend really
got me into melee and um
but like there still thinks to this day
with a game that's
at this point almost 20 years old that
people are still discovering
that's so cool and it kind of feels like
that because like not only
are we getting better at the game but
we're also learning how
each other play the game so it's like
it's this like kind of insular
thing where we're all like learning each
other's play styles and then like
adapting based on that you know there's
a
let's see but there's a fun thing that
happens in the office where when
somebody picks up a new character or
learns a new technique
for about three to four days i'll
dominate the office
and then everybody else figures that
rhythm out and for like the next three
to four days
that person who figured out the new
technique gets dominated
because you don't have a new way out of
it and then you reach equilibrium again
you kind of start winning 50 50 and it's
you know anybody's game again but that
happens once in a while where it's just
like
somebody learns a new thing and then for
the next day or two it's like they're on
top of the world
and they're the best and then it falls
apart yeah for for instance like i had
that for a solid moment it was one of
the best weeks of my life
because i had uh i had learned how to
use tilt controls so it's like
i'm using tilt control i'm using tilt
controls but i dedicated my entire right
thumb stick to tilt controls
instead of smash stick which is i mean
if you play smash you know what i mean
but if you don't sorry
and i basically spent so long playing
with tilt controls on my stick that i
eventually one day switch back to smash
controls on the stick
and that whole week i was destroying
everyone they were not ready for the
dropkicks
one after another on bowser but then
after like you're saying after a few
days people started figuring out that
rhythm
and then i just i couldn't even get past
last place consistently i went from like
dominating by a huge margin to being on
the bottom by
oh and you gave up until controls for a
while right i'm still not on till
controls that was like three or so
months ago and i haven't gone back to
till i'm still on smash sticks yeah i
don't do tilts i just
oh you don't you got a pro you got to
pro those till son you got it you got to
be
finesse dude i still stick jump that's
the thing
i stick jump as well yeah really yeah
that's like that's like the
big rule number one not to do as a pro
is like stick
jump because it gets in the way like you
you don't want to do it on accident
that's the that's the thing
and sometimes i do but um you know
obviously
it's worked out pretty well for me
[Laughter]
yeah do we even want to talk about how i
i reacted to your
of course we do of course we do that's
more that's more important
that's more important than me winning
like this what what happened
after dean one i think will go down in
history as one of the funniest things
i have ever witnessed um and
the fact that it was captured on
captured on video and captured on green
screen on green space
the best part is it will be reused for
time and memorial yeah
so so sam and i were both uh
commentating
we're i think sam should tell this story
i think this is a good story well my
side of the story is pretty boring
i'm sitting next to ren the big game
wraps up dean's the champ everyone
cheers
and screams i scream
ren screams ren continues screaming
and so on and so forth the screaming on
ren's behalf grows
and it's dominating and then suddenly
from wren
is silence and you're where are you
what are you saying in the course he's
just so excited he slams his head and
hands on the table
this what a big game he's just like whoa
what a big game
and we're all talking we're having a
great time sam's commentating
we're talking i'm talking no big deal
but now runs quiet and then runs quiet
and he gets up and
i'm still talking you know i'm a
commentator i'm not gonna stop talking
and so i turned to ren and ren's like
hey
i think i just passed out i'm like you
passed out everyone hears that
passed out we're like you passed out
because the victory was so intense
and it's like yeah like whatever i think
he tends to over exaggerate sometimes
screaming too loud
can i over exaggerate sometimes i'm like
okay i've been in situations where like
i stood up too fast and i got
lightheaded like that's what happened
you saw a couple stars yeah it's like
all right he passed out sure
well we reviewed the footage
[Laughter]
dean's victory was too intense for ren
to handle and he did
indeed pass out the lights the lights
fully went out
and he was down for a solid like three
seconds so no it wasn't that long it was
real quick
it was less than one second second yeah
but it took you a solid 15 seconds to
like
revert yeah and get your mind back on
like where am i
what happened well also you started
commentating after you were yelling
and according to you you said you didn't
remember dude
at all you had black you would argue so
what happened is that like
you can see it in the video uh the smash
happens
in like the what do you call that screen
where it's like
the the yeah the finisher screen right
right before the actual
game ends so we were like ah and i'm
like yelling haha i maintained it for
probably a few seconds longer than i
should have and i instantly go into
and dean as one and then next thing i
know i'm lifting my head off the table
uh or rather no what i remember is i'm
yelling
and then lifting my head off the table
but from watching the video i say and
dean
has one and you can see in my face i
just like
my head just goes down i immediately pop
back up and i'm just staring ahead like
i'm
so confused you know like when you wake
up from a dream and you're really
disoriented about
where you are that was what had happened
to me i was like what
and like everyone is yelling everyone's
yelling and i was like oh your
entire short-term memory got completely
wiped
and so like the last 15 seconds were
like never happened to you the first
thing i say after like 10 or so seconds
is like
dean just won yeah yeah
we ducked with it we looked at the
footage and like
you can see right when you start talking
the moment before you start talking your
eyes are just gone
and like like all the blood is rushed to
your head or something or out of i don't
forget but like
your eyeballs were just like they
weren't there
and you start you're talking and you
just
head plant onto the table
that was funny dean i couldn't i mean i
couldn't even smash my head against the
table because my body couldn't fold
enough for it
so my head just kind of like laws there
well it's funny because dean
literally hit the buttons in the right
combination to make you pass out
that's how that's how it's not good it's
how much
we care about smash brothers in the
office
well i'm excited for next year's smash
tournament yeah
actually with that story this this
podcast comes full circle
very well i think that really kind of
you can't really say anything else about
smash brothers
other than that then wren lost
consciousness
he's lost consciousness i can't wait to
see how amazing the games were
i just gotta say hope in the edit for
the note video when we get hit
and then cuts to wren and then the
background happens to him too
increases and then he falls over i want
it to be like a death note thing
like flash inverts and he's like
that has to be edited very particularly
and i think we should all be on
eyes on that edit and make sure natalie
is going to hate us
that's not right it needs to be you know
i think in the moment the first time
through it should just be kind of off on
the side
but it's the icing after the initial
and then celebration rewind that that's
the moment that can be played like three
or four times
yeah it's like more important than the
winner of the video at a certain point
it's so funny um dean that low-key there
was a hundred dollars
um prize pool you got it did you get the
hundred dollars
yeah so after i won i'm i'm feeling good
man i'm like
like i'm gonna take my girlfriend out to
dinner i'm gonna be the hero
and then i go out to my car i'm just
like yes and i try to get in my car and
it's like
the door's not opening i'm like what's
going on man
and i get in and like the engine won't
start i'm like is my battery dead
and so i i got to call triple a and i
was here until like
8 30 cause my i had to get my battery
replaced in my car
it was 180
because we passed you on the one wheel
when you're there you're like oh it's
weird i had to like open my car with the
actual key yeah cause i usually i just
use the
the fob but like yeah do this that's
dopey keeping me humble man
hey next tournament next tournament
there's a chance yeah
next tournament will make the price 200
bucks but then we'll break to your
windows so it'll even out yeah
just bitter about me winning again
that's the thing is like i don't want to
i don't want to get too good that it's
not fun to play no no no
no that's all right look that's like me
and mario kart right you cannot touch me
mario kart
that's the thing
but yeah to cap it off guys i'm glad
that you guys were playing smash bros
when i first started here because i
remember
it's like new kid at school i haven't
come in for my lunch box
and i see you guys on your socials like
oh you guys play smash bros
and then i remember i hopped in that
first game and like i reflected
something as falco was saying and sam
was like oh man you're pretty good
and i was like yes
yeah i remember that good times guys
well
i think that's the end of this podcast
you guys want to go play some smash
yeah we're definitely gonna get a few
games thanks everybody for listening i'm
not even sure if i'm on the camera right
now but
thanks everybody for listening and uh
we'll see you guys in the next podcast
if you have any things you want to want
to hear from us about or want us to talk
about feel free to leave some
suggestions in the comments
on our youtube channel on the corridor
cast because it's always great getting
inspiration from the people leave a
comment down below on who you think
should be dean's next maine
i'll take anybody i'll take pichu pichu
he's working on pichu
i'm working on pichu see dean is
purposely trying to learn the bad
characters
so that he can like beat us like uldamar
that's never gonna happen
so anyways we're getting too nerdy here
it's been enough nerdy
stuff happening already alright thanks
for listening everybody thank you see in
the next podcast
peace